There is nothing bigger
or older than the universe.
The questions
I would like to talk about are:
one, where did we come from?
How did the universe come into being?
Are we alone in the universe?
Is there alien life out there?
What is the future of the human race?
Up until the 1920s,
everyone thought the universe
was essentially static
and unchanging in time.
Then it was discovered
that the universe was expanding.
Distant galaxies were moving away from us.
This meant they must have been
closer together in the past.
If we extrapolate back,
we find we must have
all been on top of each other
about 15 billion years ago.
This was the Big Bang,
the beginning of the universe.
But was there anything
before the Big Bang?
If not, what created the universe?
Why did the universe emerge
from the Big Bang the way it did?
We used to think
that the theory of the universe
could be divided into two parts.
First, there were the laws
like Maxwell's equations
and general relativity
that determined the evolution
of the universe,
given its state
over all of space at one time.
And second, there was no question
of the initial state of the universe.
We have made good progress
on the first part,
and now have the knowledge
of the laws of evolution
in all but the most extreme conditions.
But until recently,
we have had little idea
about the initial conditions
for the universe.
However, this division into laws
of evolution and initial conditions
depends on time and space
being separate and distinct.
Under extreme conditions,
general relativity and quantum theory
allow time to behave
like another dimension of space.
This removes the distinction
between time and space,
and means the laws of evolution
can also determine the initial state.
The universe can spontaneously
create itself out of nothing.
Moreover, we can calculate
a probability that the universe
was created in different states.
These predictions
are in excellent agreement
with observations by the WMAP satellite
of the cosmic microwave background,
which is an imprint
of the very early universe.
We think we have solved
the mystery of creation.
Maybe we should patent the universe
and charge everyone royalties
for their existence.
I now turn to the second big question:
are we alone, or is there
other life in the universe?
We believe that life arose
spontaneously on the Earth,
so it must be possible for life
to appear on other suitable planets,
of which there seem to be
a large number in the galaxy.
But we don't know how life first appeared.
We have two pieces
of observational evidence
on the probability of life appearing.
The first is that we have fossils of algae
from 3.5 billion years ago.
The Earth was formed 4.6 billion years ago
and was probably too hot
for about the first half billion years.
So life appeared on Earth
within half a billion years
of it being possible,
which is short compared
to the 10-billion-year lifetime
of a planet of Earth type.
This suggests that the probability
of life appearing is reasonably high.
If it was very low,
one would have expected it
to take most
of the ten billion years available.
On the other hand, we don't seem
to have been visited by aliens.
I am discounting the reports of UFOs.
Why would they appear
only to cranks and weirdos?
If there is a government conspiracy
to suppress the reports
and keep for itself the scientific
knowledge the aliens bring,
it seems to have been a singularly
ineffective policy so far.
Furthermore, despite an extensive search
by the SETI project,
we haven't heard any alien
television quiz shows.
This probably indicates
that there are no alien civilizations
at our stage of development
within a radius
of a few hundred light years.
Issuing an insurance policy
against abduction by aliens
seems a pretty safe bet.
This brings me to the last
of the big questions:
the future of the human race.
If we are the only intelligent
beings in the galaxy,
we should make sure
we survive and continue.
But we are entering an increasingly
dangerous period of our history.
Our population and our use
of the finite resources of planet Earth
are growing exponentially,
along with our technical ability
to change the environment for good or ill.
But our genetic code
still carries the selfish
and aggressive instincts
that were of survival
advantage in the past.
It will be difficult enough
to avoid disaster
in the next hundred years,
let alone the next thousand or million.
Our only chance of long-term survival
is not to remain inward-looking
on planet Earth,
but to spread out into space.
The answers to these big questions
show that we have made remarkable progress
in the last hundred years.
But if we want to continue
beyond the next hundred years,
our future is in space.
That is why I am in favor of manned --
or should I say,
personned -- space flight.
All of my life I have sought
to understand the universe
and find answers to these questions.
I have been very lucky
that my disability has not been
a serious handicap.
Indeed, it has probably given me
more time than most people
to pursue the quest for knowledge.
The ultimate goal is a complete
theory of the universe,
and we are making good progress.
Thank you for listening.
Chris Anderson: Professor,
if you had to guess either way,
do you now believe
that it is more likely than not
that we are alone in the Milky Way,
as a civilization of our level
of intelligence or higher?
This answer took seven minutes,
and really gave me an insight
into the incredible act of generosity
this whole talk was for TED.
Stephen Hawking: I think it quite likely
that we are the only civilization
within several hundred light years;
otherwise we would have heard radio waves.
The alternative is that civilizations
don't last very long,
but destroy themselves.
CA: Professor Hawking,
thank you for that answer.
We will take it
as a salutary warning, I think,
for the rest of our conference this week.
Professor, we really thank you
for the extraordinary effort you made
to share your questions with us today.
Thank you very much indeed.
(Applause)